I'm not cutting the tariff or sentence
for anything that's decided by the
sentencing council by judges
I give them my views but there I'm not
cutting sentences for anything it's been
a myth ever since I started the reform
at the moment you get a cut in the
sentence you're given if you plead
guilty and save the witnesses the ordeal
of going through it that's the moment a
third that's the system I've taken over
and what I'm suggesting is if you do it
early and save the victim particularly
and the witnesses or the trauma of going
through the preparation for a trial
where they're going to be cross-examined
accused of lying and so on then a half
can be given as a discount but the judge
will take an account every other aspect
of the case as well and in the end the
judges sentence has got to reflect the
seriousness of the offense and rape is
obviously an exceedingly serious offense
but and this would apply there not just
to rape those rather serious offenses
burglary burglary robbery things like
that rapes been singled out as an
example but mainly to add a bit of
sexual excitement to their headlines but
also because it's a very serious offense
at the moment you're someone charged
with rape can get a third off if they
plead guilty at any stage and what we're
saying from early plea half now that if
that sounds generous firstly the person
is obviously showing genuine contrition
but the advantage is the Wigton already
shocked and traumatized by the rape is
spared the ordeal of having to relive it
be cross-examined in the court accused
of lying all the things that she will be
put through if the person who raped her
actually insists on trying to brave it
out and persuade the jury t didn't do it
but nobody gets back on the streets
after a year in a bit unique people
start illustrating cases you need to
know all the facts of the case
accurately recounted but rape is a
serious crime the starting point for
rape you know five six years goes up to
ten years that the classic rape leaps
out on an unsuspecting woman and forces
her to have sex
oh that's ten years plus usually and
they of course as a starting point then
the judge has to reflect the individual
case but
these are scare stories nobody's saying
a rape but a serious proper rape case
there's going to be let out of prison in
12 months and all the rest of it and at
the heart of it all you know is a
serious point the serious point how to
minimize the trauma for a shocked woman
who's already gone through the
experience of rape and if the man tries
to brave it out will actually then have
to relive it all and have a new ordeal
in court which is a not going to help
her to come to terms with the terrible
experience she's had